who uh are you like a fan of just as a
MC like obviously you love future yeah
best album of the year so that's my
favorite rapper ever yeah that's
interesting yeah ever ever all time Ulta
over hope
they like 181b that's interesting yeah
future all time yeah for me he's the
greatest Club artist of all time no he's
hilarious and he's a lyric he's one of
the best players he's one of the best
songwriters ever but for me it's lyrics
that relate to My Life True it probably
doesn't relate to everyone else so
you're a drug addict no I'm not a drug
addict I'm not a joke you should be
drugged out my boy I can be toxic at
times okay that's right I could be
talking I love having fun yeah
um I love looking at life from different
views I love future I love women I love
vacations I wouldn't put them I wouldn't
put them in in the top ten though I just
said he's mine I respect it or personal
like I think remember that Meme that was
going around like two years ago and it
was like field of Mount Rushmore in it
was Drake Kendrick and Cole I think
future is the fourth one
of this generation I agree yeah
yeah yeah yeah or yeah not Travis future
it's future it's for sure future yeah
it's future for sure it's not even close
not close
future yeah cause what what Tony Montana
was 2010 or 11 2010. was it 2010
[ __ ] I told him all this [ __ ]
it might have been 2011. it's 2010 or
2011. but either way it go there no he's
not a decade run and it's pretty crazy
and he's wild it's still going still
going and the new album like he had
dropped a few albums recently that I was
like but the new album the new album was
the one yeah that was great he ain't no
[ __ ] for sure and he's probably like top
six or seven most influential guy ever
in rap
I wouldn't be mad at five you got my
album at five I mean you could at least
put future and she's top five most
influential because it's like it's it's
probably like who's your top five most
influential in hip-hop
I think it's Tupac and I'm just not in
no order okay Tupac whole
actually not Jay-Z I'm sorry two Jay-Z
he's not tough one wait wait wait wait
hold on I'm thinking in order
I think like overall in the game like
all time like who made it okay to really
rap rock him and I know that's like some
old head [ __ ] to say because that's
before my journey but he was like the
first dude I'm with you on that because
before Rock him nobody was really doing
this right everywhere people walking
around Tupac Rock him Hove
Kanye and Lil Wayne
I can't argue that
because Kanye I cannot argue Has Changed
music hip-hop like four times I cannot
argue that and then it's like future
Chief Keef yeah Drake Drake even now I
can't even say that because musically he
didn't have no one to get slipped on oh
Ace Hood all right
guy great great physique so many people
stole Ace Hood style yeah I uh people
have made careers off of Ace Hood sounds
listen don't say a statement like that
and not tell me who's stolen his style a
lot of people give me one name you want
to do it the the the Migos flow the
Migos flow comes from an Ace Hood style
really
yes I guess I'm not listen to Listen to
early Ace Hood and listen to okay we're
not gonna put Ace Hood in the top ten
though I'm not saying you can put them
wherever you want to put him what I'm
saying is he gets he slept on that's
fair he's a great emcee has taken his
style and ran with him okay there's
early Meek Mill songs okay that feel
like I'm not saying Meeks though they
came at the same time so they kind of
fed off each other but that style of
Hustle Hard definitely underrated in my
pocket
drink none with no profit when I double
up with my profit that whole Flow came
from Ace Hood the same way [ __ ] rap
today all right well acid gets his
flowers today Shout Out Days very
underrated discography too very
underrated yeah very underrated shout
out days most fit rapper
most fit that [ __ ] yoked more
than 50 Cent yeah what did you see 50
hanging upside down at the Super Bowl
look like a TV put some weight on you
though man now Ace Hood is like a
[ __ ] specimen pause like that
[ __ ] is like a goddamn he's like
a The Rock
have you seen him lately no bro he's
[ __ ] jacked really like jacked it's
like
it's like he he should he should be like
fighting or playing football or
something he's [ __ ] know that I knew
he was always like a fit no no no he's
like no he fit guy it's like him and
Method Man is it him in the Rock no the
I'm talking about hip-hop like Method
Man's also pretty what about him and Vin
Diesel
I think uh Vin Diesel is probably more
flabbier than Ace Hood for sure okay
yeah okay what about the Rock and Vin
Diesel the rock is a [ __ ] alien yeah
all right did you see the baby
that they was passing around in the
Crowd Oh I thought you meant the baby
I'm gonna get a baby's kind of in all
right shape
yeah they crowd surfed the baby yeah
I don't know that was a newborn baby
just getting passed through a crowd to
go to the Rock and The Rock's just like
yeah this is weird that was some wild
[ __ ] super well that kid's parents need
to be detained